and we are joined by the man Trey young
in studio right now so this was an idol
growing up huh oh for sure do the call
First a there we go all so anyway back
to the back to the question so this was
the guy huh yeah yeah no he was
definitely one of them I mean I looked
up to a lot of guys a lot of players
growing up I mean for me one of the
things I took from Jamal he don't even
know just his bounce and his off the
dribble the Skip and to make to make you
think about or read the defender before
you make your next move is something
that just from watching this game I was
able to to learn from and now this guy
that's been watching your footage is
right up there in the Allstar voting as
well back where I think you should be
take one more look halberton Trey and
then Dame Donovan Maxi it's got to be
nice to see your name that high this
year oh it's definitely a blessing again
uh to be to be up there uh among some of
these really good players uh I mean fans
are showing a lot of love um I wish our
record was a lot better than what it is
but I mean the All-Star game is is for
the fans is for for them just so to see
them show me a lot of love uh right now
is really good for me I think he has to
be an All-Star if you look at it yeah
the vulture there but fans want to see
the Superstar players make Superstar
plays he's he's like he keeps me on the
edge of our SE me and reie standing up
yesterday that one play he had a triple
pump fake to a laup we didn't know where
you were going I'm not sure you know
where you're going sometimes but you
figure it out watching you yesterday the
game was in slow motion what are you
looking at what are your reads when
you're out there uh I mean for me I'm
always looking at the person behind my
Defender uh if I'm getting if I'm help
huh The Help The Help man uh so if I got
my big man set in the screen I'm looking
at where his man is and if he's in drop
coverage I know I'm going to be able to
turn the turn the corner and get
downhill and then I have to read where
the next help man's coming from so it's
more about just reading where the help
man's at and then just taking step by
step yeah so I've always been impressed
with your eyes and we talked about this
um yesterday we talk about it all the
time on NBA TV can you just how
important as a point guard is it to use
your eyes because there's so many times
where you're coming into a play and your
eyes make the defense change what
they're doing and so you're able to get
easy layups or get teammates easy shots
for sure it's definitely a tool I feel
like I've always tried to use is make
the I mean the Defenders go go where my
eyes go uh I they don't know where I'm
about to pass it next but I know they're
looking at me so uh to try to make the
Defenders read my eyes is something I
definitely have always been able to
think of for sure so three best Shooters
in the league are yourself Steph Curry
and Dame Lillard when you go up against
those guys do you try to how do them or
do you say oh you guys are better than
me I want to know the mentality of
another great shooter oh no I mean every
night I'd step on the court I'm trying
to I'm trying to be the best player on
the court I'm try don't give me the Corp
you go against Stephan name somebody
that's in your
category pass pass the ball pass the
ball listen there's a lot of it's only
three guys in the league that right
here stiny leg so like when you go
against those guys do you try to outdo I
mean I definitely uh you definitely get
up for those matches you definitely get
up for those those those matchups and
obviously know those guys history and
their past and what they've done before
I got into the league so it definitely
gives you extra motivation and extra I
mean reason to get up uh that morning to
go play them um but like I said again I
really try to do that every night and
you have to try to find that every night
if you want to be really good all right
so you know that sorry yeah please so
Steph comes down and hit one here in
your face are you thinking about calling
the play or you think about getting them
back right away the
smile away with the smile thinking no I
mean you know I definely I definitely
want to get him back but it's it's just
how I mean it may be me coming down and
getting a three and that may be the best
option and that may be my first look but
if somebody
corporate I being corporate I'm telling
you I'm being honest it could also be
him Crossing up somebody and I'm happy
he's here because we are starting a new
segment today sha and I think you're
going to like it so first let's show
something that's been iconic for you not
just a crossover but when you first came
into the league I hadn't really seen
many nutmegs until you started doing it
mhm take me through this take me through
this moment cuz this this had people
questioning themselves good yeah I mean
to be honest I've been doing this for a
long time like I've I've seen I've been
doing this probably since high school
like I use it really to get oh oh wow
buy my Defender it's not necessarily
just to space ridiculous show no not
through the
double there's nobody behind the
defender so I'm able to throw it between
their legs and that little quick moment
where they're just looking for it is the
time that I'm running around him so I
mean unless Trevor re is out there ain't
nobody us going I was going to say I
remember he stiff armed you right in the
chest you know Candace had a crossover
too she doesn't know we're going to show
it but maybe this is a segment for
Candace I don't know let's take a look
uh
[Music]
uhoh so the eyes well my guy left Co was
sitting cour side I
was on your feet you knowes
[Applause]
baby pull up
on right to left right to
left that would have been me but truth
be told the man that needs to do this
segment is Jamal Crawford cuz I don't
think anybody diced up people like
this one more people only try that in
warmups I haven't seen that in the game
in a long long time not very
many you know what Adam when we play
against jamor I would never show on the
screen you wouldn't show no not for you
yeah let him go guard them the new
segment that we have here on NBA on TNT
Tuesday is crossed up with Jamal
Crawford where we are going to find the
best crossovers all year long we gave
you a list you narrowed it down to four
and the fans voted they voted they voted
all right so let's give him the top
crossed up of the year so far top cross
so far for this season the fans have
spoken but these are my four so far this
season let's go desm Bay uhoh Boo no no
no got back watch it again watch it
again watch it again get it'll get watch
again there's the move watch his hands
why you put his hands up after why he
put his hands up after watch his hands
what's his hands up for got him with a
Stutter
Step Timberlake liked it number uhoh the
man next to me Trey is dancing looking
at that help defense he's in a trick bag
he's in a trick back he beats the man
and the help chains liked it Lil chains
liked it look how he's dancing through
the legs behind the Back Eyes Soul Flo
over here we already know look this
right to left stop that's trick back
uhoh oh my God that's the trick bag
that's the trick bag and Trey does that
all the time he got crossed up oh he's
got the crossed up chain number two
Shake s what are you looking for over
there I don't know what he's do jannis
liked it jnis lik watch n he he did that
Sierra one two step on that one he he
went straight to it Grant Williams liked
it Donovan approves right to left pull
back
wow di ni
change oh that's how I'm get Gilly you
already know that's how Gil's getting it
oh yeah's been kind of quiet lately been
real quiet and then step the Chef
cooking cooking Brooks ain't nothing
over there there either ain't nothing
there either that was three and one
Steph couldn't believe it Steph couldn't
one that's one two catch up we call this
catch up and then that's H sa at the end
Steph Curry getting busy we already know
those are the best four CR so far wow
don't do that don't do that so that was
four that was four Jack like he liked it
terrible so here here's how this is
going to work oh look at
thise Brown bring the camera out bring
the tape let's take a look at the
footage here so what I like about this
is the Steph crossover now is going to
be number one for the rest of the season
unless there are Challengers so this
goes to you too Trey this isn't going to
be every week where we just bring in
four yeah if there's a crossover that
shocks everyone they're going to Tweet
it to NBA on T&T and then Jamal will
decide if it overtakes the Steph Curry
cross all right how do you feel about
this as the king of crossover I feel
good about it I think it's well earned I
played against different eras I didn't
have to guard him luckily I played
against Iverson I played against Tim
Hardway I played against some of the
best Kyrie obviously so white chocolate
white chocolate shout out to White
Chocolate Baron Davis Steve Francis yeah
yeah some the best I'm excited what you
think Trey three's okay three's okay
it's okay what should you have been Trey
what the f let's talk to the fans right
now what should you have been on that
lift no I mean out of those four right
there all four great cross overs but
you're right Shaq he got that political
thing figured out fig out there you go
he said should be number one